CBS News has confirmed that more than
54,000 people living and working in
long-term care facilities have died from
the corona virus that's more than 40
percent of reported u.s. deaths at one
hard-hit facility the Holyoke soldiers
home in Massachusetts
76 residents died all of them veterans a
newly released report blames management
decisions described as quote utterly
baffling Jonathan Vigliotti reports
Susan Kenney is heartbroken over the
newly released report detailing the
missteps at the Holyoke soldiers home
her father Air Force veteran Charles
Lowell was one of the homes nearly 80
residents who died from coronavirus the
174 page report released Wednesday says
the most substantial error was the
decision to move all veterans both kovat
19 positive and those with no kovat 19
symptoms into one unit resulting in more
than 40 veterans crowded into a space
designed to hold 25 workers describe the
move as total pandemonium saying the
space resembled a war zone one social
worker said they felt they were moving
these unknowing veterans off to die the
investigation was ordered by governor
Charlie Baker veterans who deserved the
best from state government got exactly
the opposite and there's no excuse or
plausible explanation for that nursing
homes around the country have been
crushed by the pandemic about one in
five facilities have reported deaths
last week a special house panel on the
corona virus pandemic launched an
investigation Danijela turn owes 74
year-old father Dean also passed away at
soldiers home the state's attorney
general is now conducting a separate
investigation to determine if legal
action
is warranted the report also found the
homes lead superintendent Bennett Walsh
was not qualified to manage a long-term
care facility he was placed on
administrative leave in a statement
Walsh called the claims baseless the
state Secretary of Veterans Affairs has
resigned
Tony an absolute tragedy there in
Massachusetts perhaps a preventable one
and we know not the only facility where
questions are being asked Jonathan thank
you very much